My day,
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day about what the fuck are you talking about?
[inaudible] today you were dropping some knowledge on me about some gem where
they're fighting the fucking movie with a black dudes.
What's that movie that the kid came on here?
Billy Corbin did.
Oh,
dog fight.
Yeah.
And then when we told them about dog fighting,
then you're talking about some gem and you said you'd save it for the podcast.
This is what I was telling you.
Like do you know what happened with Conor Mcgregor and Nate Diaz with the
bottles?
They threw water bottles,
plastic water bottles.
They got well,
well some of them might have thrown a monster energy.
Can someone throw a cam said if it can hit you or someone you care about that
would suck the water bottles.
Like come on anyway,
they got fined $150,000 and it should definitely shouldn't fucking throw water
bottles.
Right.
So part of me is like,
well if they could discourage throw water balls,
that shit stupid.
Right.
But,
but did the altercation,
the altercations,
probably good for business.
The altercation.
I mean I get excited.
I see Nate Diaz and Conor McGregor screaming at each other cry ain't no fuck
you.
No fuck you.
Fuck you.
I can get crazy with each other.
It makes you excited.
And I think that generates paper view buys.
I don't think Conor stupid.
I don't think Nate stupid.
I think they're smart and I think they know what they're doing when it comes to
that kind of stuff.
So that's a part of the show.
I mean did he really think he was going to hit him with that water bottle?
You know fucking Nate Diaz.
It's hard to hit him with a punch.
How the fuck are you going to hit him with a water bottle that's coming from 300
feet away?
He's not going to see that.
He's not going to move out of the way of that water bottle.
You know?
I mean what they decide to get upset about and what they don't decide to get
upset about is what's weird about athletic commissions.
Yeah.
Like one of the things they were talking about whether or not they were going to
test Nate for his vape pen cause he had a CBD vape pen,
which is CBD,
not even,
not even psychoactive.
It doesn't make you high,
but it does alleviate some inflammation and it provides people that have like,
you know,
back pain or something like that or especially after a long fight provides you
with a little relief.
But what's crazy is the only reason why they would want you to not do it,
obviously it's not performance enhancing.
You're not performing anymore.
The performance is over.
So are they protecting you from yourself?
Like what are they doing?
They don't want you to do it because you're flaunting the fact that you're doing
it in front of everybody.
Like they piss him after the CBD just after he was smoking that I think he had
already done his post fight fighting.
I think you do that before you do the press conference.
I think.
I don't know though.
It's a good question.
I'm not entirely sure.
And they might do it different way differently in different places,
but either way you're not concerned about him.
Like what do you,
what?
What's the issue like what is the issue?
It's just,
it looks bad.
Does it look bad that he's dead?
Vapors coming out?
He's of dragons,
the CBD oil business.
We're not the roof then.
I'm sure it did and it should and it should.
The roof and wait and wait till it becomes illegal.
We're a month away.
When it becomes legal,
then it's really going to go nuts.
It's going to be good for everybody.
But anyway,
so they get fucking pissed at them for that.
But the,
the,
the Connor,
the fine was so high.
I'm like $150,000 wow.
Oh he said he made 40 million next time shut your mouth and they won't fucking
know.
That's true.
100 you know,
even the other kid made two,
three mil,
half of that after taxes,
1.5 on 50 don't really put a dent in your fucking thing.
Next time you won't throw fucking bottles.
That is,
you got west state bowling.
Unless they both went to Dan and say,
listen,
this jacked up the things.
So I went to see him wanting to SAP UFC,
pick up the tab,
but then with 300 because it came out of your fucking,
and for the paper views and something,
there's always one 50 is not that bad.
They walked away with a ton of loot.
It's a good point.
There's gotta be some type of repercussion.
One 50 and they can fight again in November.
Right.
Listen,
I got to court without a license 10 15 years ago in la.
First time ever.
It was talking on the phone and I got pulled over,
got goes,
where's your license?
It didn't work that day.
I went down to La County.
I stood in front of a judge,
my bipap,
the guy looked at me straight in the face and she goes,
you could pay 200 and come back with your license or give me fun 50 and I don't
want to see you again.
What do you think I did?
I gave him 200 and game five I gave him five 50 and in time I got my license.
Not with a gun to my head.
Yeah.
Sometimes you pay a little extra gonna let you fight Melvin Butler.
Now you earn next time and now you can make up that one 50 you're earning at
least they're not suspend it for fucking a year.
Yeah,
that's true.
Here's,
here's my thought,
but I don't think 150 is bad.
If you got a good charity for it,
the of the charity.
Yeah.
Instead of going to an athletic department and what I mean,
yeah,
I'm sure he has a nice apartment.
His apartment somewhere be a girl's soccer team or something like that for that
day.
That that's like a good thing.
Right.
But 300,000 into their pocket is what pisses you off.
Wow.
See what they decide to get mad at and what they don't decide to get mad at.
Because this is the thing that I found.
Do you know,
did you watch when Floyd Mayweather was doing,
I believe it was for showtime.
They were doing one of those behind the scenes things at his gym and um,
he has what he calls doghouse fights.
And I just,
let me just say that this kind of thing has been going on in Jim's forever,
right?
They've always had gym wars and people have even set up,
and this was a thing that I'm pretty sure it became illegal in California fairly
recently,
within the last decade,
they stopped allowing people to have what they call smokers and what a smoker
is.
They have organized fights.
Um,
but there's not really like a lot of medical on hand.
They're only gets paid,
nobody gets paid.
But it gives people experience.
They used to have a lot of them and Moy,
Tai,
like I used to go to them,
they were cool.
They would set up like these little plastic lawn chairs,
you'd pay a small amount of money,
you know,
like 30 bucks or something like that.
And you'd go and you watch all these amateur fights.
And a lot of times kids are pretty fucking talented and it's fun to watch.
But so they've always had organized chimp fights.
So essentially what Floyd Mayweather did was have his own,
like in house Jim fights,
like amateur fights.
Like they didn't even disguise the fact that it was a competition.
Like they weren't trying to,
uh,
they weren't trying to spar.
Like these guys are having fights
and he was talking about how it's to the death.
It's really crazy.
And he has these guys,
one guy gets beat up and he's Huck Haseem rock bonds brother or son seen Brock
months son.
I believe.
You see if you could save,
you can Google who the gentleman was saying it was his brother but I was just
his brother.
Maybe it's his brother.
That makes more sense cause how seem Rockmont is not that old to have a kid
that's that you know,
like that developed because he looks like he's like in his twenties maybe.
Yes.
Anyway,
point being so this English guy beats up Haseem Brock bonds one brother and then
the mom comes back with the bigger brother and the English guy fights him too
all in the same day and they're fighting like these 30 minute rounds just gets
crazy
cause you're a winner.
And the Lewis,
they put it on TV.
Yeah.
I mean dude,
there's definitely,
what are the losers?
I'm sorry,
the question was,
is that Jesus?
No,
I don't think there is.
I mean,
there might be,
Floyd might reward them or something like that,
but I mean it's,
it's crazy shit and I mean,
in one way,
yeah,
this'll develop,
develop character.
And I don't have a problem with people doing whatever they decide to do.
If somebody wants a fight,
a 30 minute fight,
I don't have a problem with that.
You should be able to do it if you want to.
They've been doing this and she's just love Chicago.
But the thing is in Boston,
when you do a brown belt,
yeah.
They way your buddy shoot that.
But,
um,
but the thing is I'm not a promoter in Las Vegas.
Right.
That's a big difference.
It's a big difference.
And I'm not a professional fighter on television.
I'm not,
so I'm,
you know,
I'm not,
and I'm not necessarily saying there's anything wrong with what he did because
it is a part of gym culture.
It is a part of what's made champions.
I mean this kind of stuff,
these,
this heat,
these heated battles is this uncomfortable reality that elite fighters like
Floyd Mayweather face like to be that good,
you have to be that real.
And for a guy like him to show like these kind of crazy 30 minute,
no time limit fights in the gym and put it on TV,
it's pretty wild is in,
and I see both sides of it.
I totally see Floyd made with the side of it.
Look at him,
he feeds off that.
But guess what?
That mentality is why that motherfucker was 49 and [inaudible] right?
That mother is arguably the best box forever.
Who,
who got hurt less than Floyd Mayweather who box people's face off that everybody
thought it was going to kill him better than Floyd Mayweather.
Remember when he fought my Donna and he found him the first time and um,
my,
Donna caught him in one of the exchanges like right before the bell rang.
We were like,
whoa.
And then they fought again the second time and he just put a clinic on my,
Donna just put a clinic on them.
It's like all of a sudden my Donald was finding a totally different guy.
Like Floyd had figured out my Donna's style or decided not to fuck around this
fight and decided,
you know,
to really take him seriously.
I'm really focused on him and he just beat his ass.
He different things.
A lot of ways you don't agree with a lot of this shit.
He does and you know,
but uh,
listen man,
his motion games off the charts,
off the charts,
he's self promotion games the greatest of all time.
He's my me more money.
He's made me laugh at night sometimes.
I've watched this show and he's made me laugh.
And it that show you watch because you don't really like the dude.
Yeah,
but you want,
I mean he,
you know,
I bet I would love him.
I Bet I would love it.
I would love him.
He's a psycho.
He wants to fight like three times.
I'm like,
you know what the proof was in the motherfucking pudding.
Exactly.
That's it.
Exactly is in the pudding.
Let them do whatever the fuck he wants.
You don't,
you don't get a guy like that unless he's a guy like that.
You don't get that 49 you know,
unless he's that kind of dude,
but I think he handles it as good as any fucking human being that could be in
that position,
handles it.
It's a crazy position to be in to be a young guy and be worth that much money.
And you'll know your nicknames.
Money.
Mayweather.
I mean
what the fuck names himself money me and he's hilarious.
I ain't got nothing wrong with you if you talk shit and back at yeah,
they need more exactly where I live.
You know what I'm reading right now.
A buddy of mine gave it to me,
Hollywood Henderson to you old enough for that.
Hollywood Henderson was a Dallas Cowboy.
That was the real deal.
You understand me?
They don't even make them like that.
No one showed up rookie day.
I'll give you the article with three.
It's acid,
a gram of blow right here,
the thousand oaks and then the off season.
He would rent the hotel and hang out with prior at the company store while he
would have the son was the lab would point sisters.
This was before Rick James and before they played the Denver Broncos in this
claim,
the fame,
he went on national TV and took a can of orange crush with the Denver Broncos,
drank soda and he fucking crushed it with the juice in it with one hand,
whoa.
And the Super Bowl,
he intercepted in score,
there's a line back and then he's just fucking blew up the ball with big
fucking,
you know,
he talks shit.
People,
hey,
hey.
He talks shit on Game Day.
He showed up.
Then they threw him out because he put fucking two fingers up during the game
and the owner of the cowboys saw him at that time.
What's two fingers?
He can't do two fingers illusion on TV,
on national TV and Hollywood Henderson.
The camera came over and instead of watching he advertised a towel.
He goes,
Yo,
if you need these tiles,
and they were like the receivers company.
The next day Tom Landry Find Hollywood have this.
Ah,
and after that it was all over.
He was smoking a fucking crack and bazookas but he won the lottery in Texas.
They won the lottery,
became a born again Christian.
Oh my goodness.
Ah,
oh was my motherfucker dog.
Wow.
Well that's a fun story.
That's fine.
Yeah.
I mean,
I just want to be clear about all that stuff that I was saying about the Floyd
Mayweather thing.
I just think that
athletic commissions,
you know,
like when they find people and when they get mad at people for stuff,
it's like sometimes they,
they do it in a very heavy handed way,
and I think it's kind of obscene.
Like
[inaudible]
okay.